alligators crocodiles and gharial aren't
exactly known for their easygoing
natures they get even less friendly when
you force them to run on a treadmill but
it's worth it because watching
crocodilians exercise might teach us how
dinosaurs breathe to get american
alligators to walk the custom treadmill
in his lab at Cal State San Bernardino
vertebrate physiologist Tomas over Kovac
has to tap the basis of their tails whoa
boy forward oh yes he and his colleagues
are studying how crocodilians diaphragms
work the piston like action of the
muscle displaces the guts allowing a
quicker intake of fret anonymous used to
think this resulted in a massive flow of
oxygen to the lungs four times of
increased activity the researchers found
that the piston pump action does kick in
during exercise but surprisingly it
doesn't significantly improve overall
air intake they suspect the same was
true for dinosaurs crocodilians distant
cousins over Kovich wouldn't express an
opinion on how with t-rex would do on a
treadmill
you